HE GOT A PICK AT CENTRE ALLOWING
COMING TO HELP.
JOSH ANDERSON NOT COUTURE SCORE!
TARASENKO WAKE DOMINIC WAITINGHS
IN.
HE CAN'T MOVE LATERALLY AT THIS
POINT, NO MOVEMENT OF BINNINGTO.
WINNER, WINNER SHARK DINNER
TONIGHT FOR THE BLUES.
WHAT A SAVE WITH THEA CHANGE.PE
AHO DOES AHO ACROSS THE ICE ONE
TIMER FANNED ON MY TOUT, FOR TH
CAROLINA HURRICANES, OVER THE
BOARDS, DOUGIE HAMILTON.
WHO IS TWO FOR FOUR.
INAND SCORES!
WHAT AN ABSOLUTELY JACKETS,  AT
THIS YEAR, 4 ATTEMPTS..
MOVES INCKETS W AND A SHOOT-OUT.
THREE SECONDS TO GO.
SUZUKI HAS TO HURRY.
LONG SHOTOT
FLIPPER AND MAKES A BEAUTY SAVE
RICOMES.
WIDE RIGHT IN ON BRAND HOTEL.
TAKENOT,
THAT IS ONLY THE SECOND SHOOTOUT
GOAL THE MONTREAL CANADIEIE
BOESER.
SCORES.
HE CUTS WIDE LEFT.
NOW BACK INTO THE SLOT.AUDETTE.
STOPPED BYEY PRICE.
STICK DOWN FOR FIVE-HOLE.
LEFT LEG WAY OUT IN
WIN IT. FROM TWO
VETERAN GOALTENDERS, AND VESEY
TRIES TO PULL IT AT THE LAST
SECOND AT THE BACKHAND AND29% I.
HERE COMES TATAR.
HECK OF A MOVE ON
VANCOUVER IN HIS FIRST CAREER
SHOOTOUT ATTEMPT.
SNAPPED IT WIDE!AND ROLLS
BY BLACKWOOD.AND
WINDING UP IS
JESPER BRATT WITH THE BIG FINISH
IN PITTSBURGH!
AND THE DEVILS WIN IN A BEAUTIF
BRATT AND PAVEL ZACHA.ITY AT TH
THE GAME.
>> Josh: HAD THE GREAT
FIRST OPPORTUNITY.
RINGING IN HIS EARS.HANSEN, LOO
TO GIVIV
>> Daryl: THIS IS THE PATIENCE
OF A  LIFTER.
HE ELEVATED IT AND IT
THERE.
HERE YOU GO.
>> Josh: KLINGBERG.
COMING WITIT
PREDATORS  UP.
>> Chris: LOOK HOW TO HICKEY.
TO THE PHILADELPHIA LINE.  GOESE
OTHER WAY.
IT IS MAYFIELD.  SCORES! TO THET
WITH BRIAN ELLIOTT ON HIS WAY
BACK ACROSS  MacKINNON.
MacKINNON BRINGS IT RIGHT
BACK.
TRYING TO GO SHOOTS.
AND IT WAS BLOCKED.
SAAD KELLER.
>> Matt: DEVON TOEWS.
TIED UP BY KELLER. BY
ACROSS.
WHAT A  NET.
MacKINNON IS ON IT.
NOW BACALTZ.
1:22 FOR THE
WATCHED BY LARSSON COMES RIGHT
BACK IN OVER THE LINE.
AVALANCHE AND KADRI LOOKING TO
HE'S HAD ABOUT 10 IN THE LAST
>> Matt: JOONAS DONSKOI HAS BEEE
BOOTH JUST WATCHING THAT.OTER
AND GARLAND IS IN ON JOHANSSON.
BARELY.
SEE HOW LOW CONOR GARLAND IS.HE
AVALANCHE, NATHAN Ma
SCORES!
GAME OVER!ORAK PULLED THIS ONE F
HIS BAG OF
RETRIEVES THE PUCK.
IN ONE MOTION HE IS ABLE TO
FIND SEBASTIAN AHO.
ALONG WITH TAVARES OUT FRONT.
STUTZLE OUT IT BACK FOR TAVARES,
NORRIS, TWO-ON-ONE AND NORRIS,
OH,
REBOUND, WIDE.
AND NYLANDER CHOPPING IT BACK IN
FRONT.
[ WhistlNOCKS THAT PASS AWAY, B
COMES AUSTON  HE HUNTS IT DOWN.
AND HE'S GOT A CHANCE RIGHT IN
NEAR THE FRONT OF THE NET, THIS
OND STRAIGHT GAME